think these guys the numbers that they
produce is just mind-blowing really my
games you play my goals have scored
again my titles they've won
um I speak for yourself two of the best
players in in World football who did you
find harder to come up against between
Ronaldo and Messi um I don't know to be
honest very different players again
Ronaldo had more of it he had more of a
presence in the Box he could score goals
with his head both of them on the pitch
had that kind of aura about him that
kind of respect whereas people are
coming shut them down and almost stopped
two yards away from them probably
because they didn't want to be made to
look stupid so they almost commanded
that respect from from the players
people was kind of a bit nervy around
him because of what they can do to you
so two two big presents on a football
pitch
um so I can't choose between them who do
you thinks the best of all time they're
trying to get this out I mean I like you
do you try it you're trying uh I can't I
can't choose
I can't choose it does the numbers are
just just incredible and obviously very
similar so it's very difficult to choose
I think